merci merci c'est très heureux ce soir
il faut commencer le premier morceau
c'est une maladie gagne alors je compte
sur vous pour faire l'ambiance des
grandes corridas de la costa brava avec
les os les hérésies ouais voilà comme
s'ils étaient les gitans des saintes
maries de la mer
il me faire de temps en temps des
castagnettes comme ça si possible en
mesure et pour vous jouer sept magasins
j'ai fait appel à un guitariste un
virtuose de la guitare virtuose
extraordinaire qui tarit ste rita lau
flamengo qui essaya ma marcel l'itas des
plâtres à voilà
pas aussi qu'on est chrétiens médias
lors c'est par là commence espagnol as
qui est là qui n était à 302 malaga n'y
a
les barons si cause libyenne